[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
just
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
thank you for joining today's conference
call with governor andrew cuomo
i will now turn it over to governor
cuomo sir please go ahead
good afternoon everyone we have melissa
de rosa
dr howard zuckerbergica beth garvey
thank you for joining us today let me
give you an update
covet update positivity 3.11
74 new yorkers passed away from covert
yesterday they are in our thoughts and
prayers
number hospitalized 46 34
down 101 lowest number since december 6.
that is great news 935 patients in icu
lowest numbers since december 7
639 intubated yesterday that's down 26.
that's good news positivity by region
number one which is not a good thing
you don't want to be number one in this
4.4
long island 4.2 new york city 3.9
north country 1.9 capital region 1.8
western new york 1.7
finger lake 1.6 mohawk 1.4
central new york point 8 southern tier
0.6
that comes out to 3.13
in new york city take your guess bronx
number one 4.9
staten island 4.8
which is a turnaround queens 4.6
brooklyn 4.3 manhattan still
only 2.82 on vaccines
we administered 6 million to date
percent of new yorkers with at least one
vaccine dose 21
percent of new yorkers completed vaccine
10 percent
we've done 178 000 vaccines in the last
24 hours
more than one million doses have been
administered
in the past seven days the president's
announcement last night
is going to have a major ramification on
state's vaccination capacity
he has moved up dramatically
the amount of vaccines that are
available
and that is a good thing obviously
remember when we started we were talking
about
june july august the president is now
talking about many one
that means we have to have a tremendous
increase in our capacity to vaccinate
and that is a logistical undertaking
unlike anything we have done before
so we're going to be preparing for that
but the president's announcement that
may 1
vaccines everyone will be eligible for a
vaccine
what that means is uh in new york 15
million people will be eligible
and we have to have the capacity
to address those people as quickly as
possible
the president said it doesn't mean
everybody gets a packaging
on may 1. but
once you tell people they are eligible
then
eligibility suggests now i should be
able to get it
we're going to dramatically increase our
capacity to that
because we are we are not at the
capacity now
we've been working on a marijuana bill
i've had a number of conversations
with members the staff is working on
over this weekend we've been making good
progress
the president has
passed the federal budget bill
which is good news for new york the
federal bill we asked for
15 billion dollars
it's still uh do about two and a half
billion dollars
short from what we asked for
but it is it is a major relief
i'm going to sign the death benefits
bill today
may of last year we signed a bill into
law that provided enhanced death
benefits for families of public workers
who died from covid
i extended it by executive order today
i'm signing a new bill into law
extending that through next year 2022
it's the least we can do to say thank
you and honor
and remember the families going forward
uh the vaccinations time off bill
i'm also signing that grants each
employee
in new york both public and private paid
time off to get a covid vaccine
up to four hours per shot so this
corresponds to the president's new
directive
this will ensure that all new yorkers
have an opportunity to get vaccinated
our goal is to be the covet safe
state
[Music]
there's also a bill on unemployment
insurance benefit changes
many states have overpayment waiver
options new york does not have that
currently
but going forward we're going to ensure
it
uh you earn less than 150 000 of the
federal poverty
level through no fault of you your own
you've been overpaid
this would constitute a hardship
uh so we're not going to require people
to repay
or have it deducted from their future
benefits the
pandemic was brutal on everyone
and brutal economically uh and if this
is a way we can help
uh then that's what we want to do uh let
me make
a statement and then we'll take your
questions
uh as i have said before and i firmly
believe
and my administration is always
represented women have
a right to come forward and be heard
and i encourage that fully but i also
want to be clear
there is still a question of the truth
i did not do what has been
alleged period
i won't speculate about people's
possible motives
but i can tell you as a former attorney
general
who's gone through this situation many
times
there are often many motivations for
making an allegation and that is why you
need to know the facts
before you make a decision
there are now two reviews underway
no one wants them to happen
more quickly and more thoroughly than i
do
let them do it
i'm not going to argue this issue in the
press
mostly right that's why
they are called serious
as i've told new yorkers many times
there are facts
and then there are opinions and i've
always separated the two
when i do briefings i put out the facts
and then i offer my opinions but they
are two
different concepts
politicians who don't know a
single fact but yet
form a conclusion and an opinion
are in my opinion reckless and dangerous
the people of new york should not have
confidence
in a politician who takes the position
without knowing any facts or substance
that my friends is politics at its worst
politicians take positions for all sorts
of reasons
including political expediency and
bowing
the pressure but people know the
difference
between playing politics
bowing to council cancel culture
and the truth people know the difference
between playing politics
bowing to cancel culture and the truth
let the review proceed i'm not going to
resign
i was not elected by the politicians i
was elected by the people
part of this is that i am not part of
the political club
and you know what i'm proud of it
uh this is all that i'm going to say on
this topic
at this time i made a promise to the
people of the state
i have a job to do i've been doing it
for 11 years
this is probably the most critical time
in the state's history
everything that i have learned in the
federal government as attorney general
as governor i am bringing
bringing to the table at this moment
we have a budget due in two weeks for a
state
that is in fiscal crisis
it will be the most difficult budget we
have done
we have to perform 15 million
vaccinations
and we have to be ready on may 1 for
eligibility for the entire state
never been done before and then we have
to rebuild our state
from the bottom up because we have
serious
issues all across the state
especially in new york city that is my
job
that's why i was elected that's
what i am supposed to do and that is
exactly what i'm going to focus on
uh for the people of the state look they
have known me for 40 years
elected me attorney general they elected
me governor three times
i have been in the public eye my entire
life my entire life
i have been under public scrutiny
since i was 23 years old and ran
my father's campaign
new yorkers know me
uh wait for the facts
wait for the facts then
you can have an opinion i am
confident that when new yorkers
know the facts from the review
i am confident in the decision
based on the facts but
wait for the facts an opinion without
facts
is irresponsible i'm going to focus on
my job
because we have real challenges and
people who say avoid distractions
i'm going to avoid distractions and i'm
going to focus on my job
i have to get a budget done i have to
get
vaccinations done i have to rebuild the
state
and i'm going to
cooperate and wait for the reviews so we
actually have the facts
and then we can have an intelligent
conversation
questions operator yes sir as a reminder
to ask a question
you will need to press star one on your
telephone to withdraw your question
press the pan key
your first question is from andres if
wnbc tv
your line is open governor good
afternoon i have
two questions for you the first question
is do you say
that an opinion without facts is
irresponsible
some of the lawmakers who called for
your resignation today include
congressman jerry nadler uh
congresswoman carolyn maloney
congresswoman grace may
are you saying that those elected
officials are irresponsible
and my second question is you have said
repeatedly that you never
touched anyone inappropriately
is there a misunderstanding where their
in your mind was
consensual touching taking place in one
or more allegations
yeah let's do two things look i respect
uh
i respect any elected officials right to
take a position
on anything but as i said
my way is know the facts before you have
an opinion
oh this is a serious allegation well
then you should take it seriously right
and to take it seriously means you need
the facts
before you come to a conclusion
how do you come to a conclusion before
you know the facts well this person
alleged this
i was attorney general andrew
a lot of people allege a lot of things
for a lot of reasons
uh you never heard me as attorney
general go out and talk about an
allegation
until we were confident that there was
a basis and we had reviewed the facts
any politician can take any position on
any given day
uh that's their right uh do i think it
is
responsible to take a position on a
serious allegation
before you know any facts no i don't
think it's responsible
uh on your point on your second point
look it's very simple i never harassed
anyone i never abused anyone
i never assaulted anyone
now and i never would right
now is it possible
that i have taken a picture with a
person
who after the fact says
they were uncomfortable with the pose in
the picture
yes and that's what you're hearing about
now i have taken thousands of pictures
i never meant to make anyone feel
uncomfortable i never meant to make
anyone feel
awkward uh there are times when
i go to take a picture with a person and
i can feel that they're
standoffish or something and i respect
that
uh i never took a picture with a person
who said
i'm uncomfortable and then did it anyway
but yes i can i apologized
for people who i have taken pictures
with
and who after the fact said they were
uncomfortable
with that picture
next question operator yes sir your next
question
is from morgan mckay of spectrum news
your line is open
thank you um so governor at this point
many democratic lawmakers those in your
party
have lost faith in your ability to lead
up at what point would you step down if
an impeachment investigation were to
begin
would you resign also what is your
current opinion on the
launch of the impeachment investigation
by the assembly judiciary committee
and then third question for you why did
your administration edit
a health report regarding nursing home
statistics after it had been
submitted by health officials why did
your administration
knew more than these health officials
thank you
okay uh first morgan the
uh my point is let's get the review and
then let's get the facts
and then new yorkers can make a decision
once they have facts
you don't have facts now you have
allegations
well uh why don't i debate it in the
press
no that's not the way things are done so
i think the assembly
and the attorney general that's the
right way to do it do a review
get the facts tell the facts to the
people of the state and then we take it
from there
uh on the review i'll ask beth to
respond
but you should know it is commonplace
where an agency works on a report
with the chamber that is the common
uh operating procedure
it's not that an agency just does a
report and puts it out and
then we read about it in the press
because there are a lot of in the
chamber you have a variety of expertise
so that happens that is the normal
operating
protocol but let me ask beth
about the uh health department
yes morgan we we can send you our prior
comments on
on this matter the report was
done in collaboration with the
department of health
and so we can refer you back to those
comments
next question operator yes sir and
the next question is from david evans of
abc channel 7
your line is open hey governor can you
hear me
yes sir dave hey governor you know i
wanted to ask
um along the same line of question that
andrew asked just a second ago
and forgive me here for being a little
blunt but i i think the question that a
lot of us have is
was there some kind of a consensual
romantic relationship with any of these
women
that you understood
yeah look uh
go ahead
dave my statement could not be clearer
i think i never harassed anyone
i never assaulted anyone
i never abused anyone
to the extent you get these people who
say well he took a picture with me and i
was uncomfortable
i apologized for that
uh and i'm sure you know look i took
thousands of pictures
i'm sure you can do this all day long
uh when we take these pictures we take
them in public dave
there's a photographer there it's not
like they're done
in secret they literally
are being photographed
i mean i am in crowds
of hundreds of people
when we're taking these pictures you
know they stand on receiving lines
for a long time to take the picture
but what is being alleged
simply did not happen
and that's why you have to wait to get
next question operator
your next question is from julius papa
of 10
[Music]
wins radio your line is open
uh good afternoon governor i was
wondering
how you think you can effectively lead
amidst the allegations and the calls for
your resignation
and these growing investigations
julia i have to get a budget done with
the legislature in two weeks
uh they are doing an investigation
and uh that's fine and we'll cooperate
with the investigation
in the meantime we're going to negotiate
a budget
uh in the meantime i have to do millions
of vaccines
and this is not the first time that
we've had to walk and chew gum here
right
we had to fight covid for a year
and we had to keep the state running uh
i've even gone through situations in my
administration
where we had terrible emergencies and
floods and disasters and we had to take
care of that
and we had to do everything else at the
same time i had to fight donald trump
for four years
every day and run the state
i've had investigations before in the
state
that went on for years
by federal prosecutors and continued
to operate the state so you know
uh the assembly has their job to do
they handed it off to a committee
they're doing that job
fine we now have two weeks to do the
budget
i have to do the vaccines and
this is how government works you handle
multiple issues
at the same time uh and
i don't think there's a person in a
better position
to help the state get through this
period
then the experience that i bring to it
this is not going to be an easy budget
to do i'm telling you that right now
it's not going to be easy to get these
vaccinations done i'm telling you right
now
uh so i think i can be of tremendous
help
and i'm focused on my job i
the assembly is focused on their job and
the senate is focused on their job
so i'm confident that if everybody does
their job
we'll make do the best we can now the
budget
is hard the budget is hard to get done
on time every year right and this
is probably the hardest budget that
we've ever
done this is also probably
the most polarized political
climate that we have
you have very different theories
within the democratic party right now
you've seen it at play nationally you've
seen it at play here
that is one of the factors that is going
on right
no situation happens in a vacuum
this is a political environment that we
are
operating on and uh
politics is part of all of this
uh but uh i just
will focus on my job in the meantime i
want to make it clear
that what is being alleged just
did not happen uh the last allegation
is not true
and uh i have not had
a uh sexual relationship that was an
appropriate
period
okay thank you all very much
thank you bye
ladies and gentlemen this concludes
today's conference call
and thank you for participating you may
now disconnect
[Music]
you